josh chad congratulations all you need
to do now is defeat the man standing
next to you in our final round of
competition in which we send you back to
your home for just for five days to
recreate an iconic weapon from history
[Music]
a pair of bog
wow
meaning tiger's claw bog knock was a
ruthless weapon originating from india
while concealed in the hand it could
serve up surprise attacks resulting in
deep gashes that pierced through both
skin and muscle this variation was
called the bishwa bog knock and included
a lethal blade that was made to resemble
the sting of a scorpion this design made
it a triple threat where it could either
thrust slash or claw its way into an
opponent
one of the most well-known uses of the
weapon is recounted in the history of
the murata empire when emperor shivaji
secretly wore a bog knock and fatally
disembowelled his enemy
good luck blade smiths we'll see you in
five days
good luck look
my name is josh prince i started forging
because my younger son wanted me to
forge him a weapon for his action figure
so i forged a miniature sword for him
since then i've moved on to real blades
i plan to start working on the claws
which is going to be a challenge i got
to work on each one individually i have
to keep them the same the entire time
now that i've got the claws in the next
step is heat treat
a lot of things can go wrong i can
overshoot the temperature and create
problems in the steel especially at the
tip of the blade
overheating would make it easier to
break
if it cracks or warps i start over again
oh
it looks like it took a war
i hope i'm wrong because i don't have
time to start over from zero
maybe not
[Music]
it's pretty straight
i don't know if i was seeing things or
what when i quenched a second blade just
beautiful i can't believe it i got both
these blades through heat treat
they look pretty good the rest of it is
just fine detail work the thing i'm most
proud of are the design elements that i
put into the blade
i love the forge black handle and the
stark contrast between the handle and
the blade the tiger eye stones really
bring the whole thing together as a
tiger claw there's a little scorpion
stinger at the back too
[Music]
my name's chad hatfield and i'm a
full-time ironworker being an ironworker
really helps me in the forge because we
know a bunch of types of steel we work
with torches we work with hand tools all
the time so i am going to win
i want a nice bold pattern and hopefully
at the end of the day i have the billets
done
that turned off beautiful
i'm liking it claws are even
it's time to get ready for heat treat
there's five blades that i have to heat
treat on one blade so it's very
difficult
is a very straight blade
time for the second one
i'm liking it it looks really nice i'm
gonna put on the leather wrap for the
handles to give it a little extra grip
and to conceal the welds that i put on
there
i'll test it and see if i like it
i think it'll be sufficient for
stabbing it can take a lot of abuse
and also has a sharp edge
that's sharp
i feel really confident about these
blades i can't wait to see them being
tested
bladesmiths to see what kind of lethal
damage your weapon will do i'll take
your bag and deliver multiple slashes
and thrust and claw at the spit carcass
joshua first you ready for this it's all
ready
to be my tiger claw today please welcome
back my brother archie marcaida
[Music]
[Music]
all right josh first up it's comfortable
my three fingers in the middle allow me
to grasp on to the claws easily and not
feel that it's going to impede my
movement with a hand the clawing is very
deep your slashes cut deep into this big
carcass overall your bag
will kill good job thank you all right
chad your turn you ready yes sir
all right chad first up the handle it's
on the thinner side there's a little bit
of movement there
but the positions where you have the
claw is secure it's safe
they're razor sharp on the lacerations
there the slicing it cuts deeply
overall your weapon will kill thank you
well rj i can see it your fighting
skills have not changed since we were
kids you still scratch like a girl cat
class
thank you very much i hope you had a lot
of fun
next up is the strength test ben
blade smith to test the strength and
durability of your bog noc i'm gonna be
clawing and stabbing away at these logs
remember this test is all about what
happens to your blades not what happens
to the law
joshua first you ready i'm ready
[Music]
[Music]
oh josh the claws held up very well
there's no mark on them that they've
ever even seen a tree
but
they lost your tips
yep the first one went as i started to
pry but the second tip it cracked as
soon as i stabbed in
i liked the feeling of these in my hands
they were comfortable to wield
but they can't deny that they're not
there anymore
chad you're up next you ready yes sir
well chad
you lost one of your tips
the other one was scaring me but it's in
one piece it held up well
i like that you did damascus i like the
pattern of it it's really pretty
overall well done thank you
[Music]
all right gentlemen to test the
sharpness of your blades i'll be clawing
and slashing at our sandman here unlike
the strength tests this is all about
what your weapons do to this target
josh you're up first are you ready for
this i'm ready
[Music]
all right josh
these are sharp
you can see these cuts just clean rakes
across the chest
no tearing
i actually like that hook you've got
these are definitely cutters nicely done
thank you
all right chad you're up you ready yes
sir
all right chet
these are amazingly sharp each one of
those cuts is beautiful and clean
they're very light very fast i think you
did a beautiful job these are very nice
weapons thank you
bladesmiths what started as a round one
nuts and bolts challenge came down to
these bog knock both of you have put in
an incredible amount of work
unfortunately in this arena of
competition there can only be one forest
of fire champion
chad
congratulations you are a new fortune
fire champion good job
josh unfortunately your bog knock did
not make the cut please surrender your
weapons
i'm a little discouraged a little
disappointed but uh i'll bounce back
chad congratulations you are the new
forest and fire champion and that's a
title that comes with a check for how
much 10 000. that's right 10 000 good
job
please present your weapons to the
judges i'm feeling really good right now
that's
loss for words
being fortunate fire champion was
surreal
i was able to show my best and it makes
me feel really proud
you